Speaker 1: Many of you have been emailing
me saying, David, you're on Rumble, the right
wing sort of clone of YouTube.
Are you going to get truth social?
Trump's right wing clone of Twitter?
And the answer is I've actually tried, but
I'm unable to get on and many questions as
to why yet another one of these right wing
app launches has gone horribly wrong.
And indeed, there are now reports that Donald
Trump is completely furious about the failure
of this completely farcical social media app.
The Daily Beast is reporting that Donald Trump
is just going completely bonkers as Donald
Trump weighs another run for the White House.
He embarked on a new business opportunity,
which is truth social, and it's looking like
an embarrassing dud.
In recent weeks, sources have heard the former
president on the phone swearing gratuitously
and asking things like What the f is going
on?
He's repeatedly groused about the negative
press and the less than stellar optics of
the rollout.
These sources said.
And he's demanded to know why more people
aren't using it, why the app isn't swiftly
dominating the competition now.
I think there's actually two parts to this.
There's the technical disaster, and there's
the part where not a lot of people care about
the app on the technical side.
When I tried to sign up, I don't have an iPhone,
so I couldn't.
I couldn't.
I just had to get on a beta.
Yeah, a beta.
No on a waiting list for the Android beta.
And so if you don't have an iPhone, you're
just out.
But even people with iPhones have said, you
know, they're like number 80000 on the waitlist
and it just doesn't go anywhere.
So there's like the technical side, but also
what's the point of the app?
I mean, what I mean by that is what they basically
marketed as is, you know, all of the stuff
we can't say everywhere else because it's
disinformation and violates terms of service.
You will be allowed to say here, so come here
to say it.
But then the problem is it's just a stupid
echo chamber and it's just the people that
spread the misinformation, spreading it to
each other.
And then like journalists who just want to
see what's going on or people like me who
I'm like, Well, it sounds funny, I'll try
to sign up.
But so there's the technical problem and the
fact that not that many people are interested
in this.
So everything, everything going wrong.
If the preliminary traffic numbers are of
any indication, the former president and current
wannabe social media mogul has a point about
the low traffic the Daily Beast reviewed analysis
of visits to truth social and these are they
describe the numbers as anemic and that Trump's
truth social is doing worse or the same as
other MAGA social sites like Gab Getter.
And then you've got Rumble Rumble seems to
actually be doing a little bit better, but
it's not going particularly well, and I don't
know as far as the waiting list how even if
everybody from the waiting list got on, it
still doesn't seem like it would be particularly
successful.
So I don't really pretend to know what it
would take to launch a real, bona fide competitor
to like Twitter, Facebook, YouTube, etc. because
I'm the first to admit that, you know, there's
these network effects.
And so when we say, Well, if you don't like
the rules on YouTube, start your own fine.
Sure.
We also have to concede that once YouTube
has so much market power, it becomes more
and more difficult to really build something
successful.
As an alternative, I completely get that.
But at the same time, the premise here like
this is where you go for your right wing stuff.
They call it for free speech, where you can
say anything but you actually can't like try
criticizing Trump on some of these platforms
you actually will get will get banned, but
you need to appeal to someone other than those
people in order to build a successful app.
Because the hardcore MAGA people that are
so hardcore that they'll abandon Twitter and
Facebook for something like this, it's a relatively
small crowd, and so it was clear what this
was going to be.
There's other platforms trying to fill the
niche of like the hard right MAGA clown type
platform, and it's unlikely that this is going
to succeed.
My prediction?
It's very quietly never spoken about.
They don't shut it down because shutting it
down would be admitting defeat.
They just don't really talk about it.
And if asked.
Trump says there's great interest in it's
continuing to build.
That's my prediction.
Let me know what
you expect.